là
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
été formés de gens merveilleux et de
aidé de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter
les faits ni sur la liste des morts nés
sur la bbc mishal it et hopitalisé il
était nulle part parce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane et en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
excellente soirée à toutes et à tous
bienvenue sur arte france pour une heure
et demie d'émission comme chaque jour du
lundi au jeudi jusqu'à 21h30 place au
décryptage des grands titres de
l'actualité de la journée et au
programme de ce mardi 23 novembre
nouvelle alerte de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé après avoir prédit
un demi million de morts pour l'europe
d'ici à février l'om est ce prêt vient à
nouveau aujourd'hui et craint désormais
le décès de sept cent mille personnes
d'ici le printemps sur le vieux
continent en france nouveau conseil de
défense sanitaire demain troisième dose
port du masque obligatoire confinement
télétravail quelle mesure on attend vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme
d'ayrté france la question le
gouvernement communique-t-il
correctement au tour du côté de disney
adoption cet après midi par le parlement
européen à strasbourg de la nouvelle
politique agricole commune et ce après
près de trois ans et demi de
négociations le texte entrera en vigueur
en janvier 2023 une nouvelle formule pas
assez ambitieuses pour l'environnement
selon les verts et une partie de la
gauche une usine à gaz d'après nombre
d'exploitants comment les agriculteurs
français voient t'il vraiment cette
réforme comment lutter concrètement
contre le mal être dans le monde
agricole les réponses en deuxième partie
de cette émission
enfin au sommaire dès 21h les
révélations de 10 close selon le média
d'investigation l'egypte détourna dr
enseignement antiterroriste fournies par
la france pour traquer et tuer des
trafiquants présumés dont des civils le
journal en ligne publie des documents
explicite de la direction du
renseignement militaire français pas de
réaction du quai d'orsay alors que le
site dispose n'est plus accessible au
caire
énième conseil de défense sanitaire
demain matin à l'elysée pour tenter de
répondre à une cinquième vague de colis
de 19 jugés fulgurante par le
gouvernement entre tout de suite katia
technique devant le ministère de la
santé avenue de ségur appareils
katia télétravail confinement ou dose de
rappel quelles mesures sont envisagées
par le gouvernement
bien grégory on ne peut pas vraiment
encore spéculer mais la situation laisse
présager quelques options dont certaines
seront tranchées demain le contexte vous
le savez c'est la recrudescence
spectaculaire des infections est un
mouvement qui va en s'accélérant trente
mille cas déclarés positifs ce mardi
avec toutes les incertitudes qui en
découlent sur la capacité des hôpitaux à
ne pas être saturée a résisté en fin
d'année donc la réunion du conseil de
défense demain en présence d' emmanuel
macron devra déterminer des options de
freinage pour cette cinquième vague qui
reparaît assez grande la première depuis
la campagne de vaccination on sait par
exemple que certains pays comme
l'autriche ou la slovaquie ont mis en
place des restrictions assez forte comme
par exemple le confinement des non
vaccinés rien de tel pour le moment en
france mais dont il n'y a pas par
exemple d'obligations de couvre-feu mais
bien sûr on évoque la question de la
troisième dose la haute autorité de
santé l'a recommandé pour les plus de 40
ans mais le ministre de la santé olive
et veyran voudrez peut-être le proposer
à tous les majeurs je propose de
l'écouter
vous savez très bien que la veille d'un
conseil de défense le ministre que je
suis ne révèle pas par avance des
décisions qui n'ont pas encore été actée
mais je note que la haute autorité de
santé nous encourage à
à recommander la vaccination la
troisième dose la vaccination de rappel
dans tous les français âgés de 40 ans et
plus dès lors qu'ils sont à six mois de
la dose précédente il ya très peu de
quadragénaires dans notre pays qui sont
déjà six mois la deuxième dose ça
arrivera au cours du mois de décembre
progressivement donc ça nous donne la
possibilité de nous organiser si la
décision était entérinée demain autre
piste c'est logique celle du télétravail
puisque la recommandation a été allégé
depuis six mois pour le moment en tout
cas pas de prix de fermeture
d'établissement de prévisions ou ou de
prévision de fermeture de commerces il
est clair que le gouvernement cherche à
sauver les fêtes de noël et katia on a
eu aussi des nouvelles cet après midi de
jean castex test était positif hier soir
aux copies de 19
oui absolument testés positifs comme
vous le dites une de ses filles 11 ans a
été d'abord déclaré atteintes du virus
donc jean castex était qu'à contacter il
s'est donc isolé et le test pcr est
tombé il est positif il souffre de
symptômes légers d'une faible tout donc
son emploi du temps on va être aménagée
pour qu'ils continuent à travailler mais
le problème c'est qu'il a eu une réunion
en présentiel en belgique hier et donc
des officiels belges ont été placés à
l'isolément cinq ministres et puis
toujours sur le front du coc vide alors
cet autre chose mais c'est la situation
dans les écoles jean michel blanquer le
ministre de l'éducation nous donne des
explications
remonter les chaînes de combines de
contamination être capable de tester
c'est fondamental et ce qui est vrai
dans la société en général est vrai
aussi dans l'école en particulier et là
il s'agit surtout de l'école primaire où
nous déployons les tests les tests
salivaires mais aussi de nouvelles
expérimentations que peut-être nous
élargirons ces prochains temps pour
tenir compte de la situation c'est vrai
qu'elle est difficile au moment où je
vous parle six mille classes sont
fermées et je rappelle que l'année
dernière au pic de l'épidémie quand nous
réussissions à maintenir l'école ouverte
nous étions quand même à douze mille
classes fermées donc nous continuons à
piloter cela notamment au travers de la
stratégie tester alerté protéger donc
vous voyez grégory simi classes fermées
c'est la moitié du chiffre durant le pic
et idées et puis des mille pardons mais
avec une situation qui se dégrade à
grande vitesse donc c'est pas très
rassurant demain le conseil de défense
va devoir à cet égard précisé deux
nouvelles tactiques ou de nouvelles
restrictions merci katia technique pour
toutes ces précisions en direct du
ministère de la santé à paris merci
également à stéphane puccini qui vous
accompagnent derrière la caméra et alors
que les cas quotidiens de covile 19
augmente donc le secteur hospitalier se
dit inquiète selon une note de la
direction générale de la santé en l'état
actuel des effectifs il sera impossible
de gérer un afflux de patients à noël
elle suggère donc de réquisitionner des
soignants plus de précision avec lima
rossi devant l'hôpital européen
georges-pompidou appareils ils ne l'ont
pas bien accueilli les soignants cette
note de la direction générale de la
santé il s'agit d'un document de quatre
pages adressée à tous les professionnels
du secteur les autorités y détaille les
leviers d'action pour continuer faire
tourner les hôpitaux pendant l'hiver
notamment les services d'urgence et on
résumer ce que dit cette note est bien
c'est que les soignons pourront être
réquisitionnés pour faire face à
l'afflux de patients le texte évoque
même une mobilisation possible des
professionnels retraités certains
personnels hospitaliers craignent ainsi
de devoir passer les fêtes de noël à
l'hôpital alors que beaucoup d'entre eux
sont harassés par deux années de
pandémie ça va être une catastrophe
parce que les médecins qui sont encore à
l'hôpital eux ils restent déjà tout en
serrant les dents quand ils vont
apprendre qu'en plus ils vont être
réquisitionnés pour aller aux urgences
mais au secours la réquisition un
certain nombre de personnels risque de
s'y soustraire en disparaissant de la
circulation ça fait deux ans qu'on a été
obligé de reporter d'annuler nos
vacances personnellement j'ai un an sur
mon compte épargne temps je vais les
prendre quand d'autant que le coc vide
n'est pas le seul responsable les
professionnels de santé alertent depuis
longtemps sur le manque chronique de
personnel le système hospitalier
français connaître est même une
hémorragie des personnels médicaux ou
paramédicaux selon certains or réduction
programmée au début de l'automne 6 % des
lits étaient fermés selon la fédération
hospitalière de france dans la majeure
partie des cas du fait d'un manque
d'infirmières ou de praticiens environ
13 % de nos lits étaient fermés début
novembre contre 10 9% fin septembre nous
avons 1200 postes d'infirmières non
pourvus sans compter les infirmières
spécialisées les manipulateurs radio et
d'autres les tensions sont très fortes
notamment sur le personnel de nuit qui
représente entre 35 et 40% des postes
vacants le patron de l'ap-hp a par
ailleurs déclaré ce lundi que les
conséquences de la cinquième vague sur
l'hôpital ne sont pas attendus avant fin
décembre début janvier si elle devait se
produire et oui parce que grâce à
l'immunité chaque jour plus répandue
dans l'hexagone on peut raisonnablement
espérer que les personnes contaminées
seront moins nombreuses à développer une
forme grave de la maladie qu au cours
des vagues précédentes le coc vide
pourrait donc peser moins fort sur le
système hospitalier qu'il ya un an la
note de la dgs rappelle d'ailleurs je
cite que les difficultés à remplir les
tableaux de garde ou à maintenir une
offre de soins complète sont récurrentes
depuis plusieurs années pendant les mois
d'hiver et d'été et il faut se rappeler
que les professionnels de santé
manifestait déjà avant la crise du coc
vide pour plus d'embauchés à l'hôpital
si les soignants devront passer noël au
travail ce ne sera donc pas uniquement
en raison du coc vide mais bien aussi à
cause des politiques de santé menées ces
dernières années
l'étude flash mené à fin octobre par le
professeur delfraissy le président du
conseil scientifique révéler carli sur
cinq étaient fermés dans les hôpitaux
alors que la cinquième vague inquiète et
que le premier ministre est placé à
l'isolément le gouvernement comme
inutile correctement autour du combi de
19 on attend vos réactions sur le pont
télégramme verte et france tout de suite
place au décryptage
[Musique]
et sur ce plateau eric alauzet bonsoir
vous êtes député sur la république en
marche du doubs alexis poulain est
également présent éditorialistes rt
france et puis bruno m'égare ban est
avec nous également un petit peu un
petit peu plus loin en attend une
meilleure connexion pour pouvoir la voir
il est la renault mégane bonjour vous
êtes le chef du service réanimation de
l'hôpital lariboisière à paris
merci messieurs d'être présent pour
parler donc de cette cinquième vague je
commence avec vous à eric alauzet
christophe c'est sur le compte
télégramme d'ayrté france dit ceci je
cite ils savent bien communiquer quand
il s'agit de restriction pour les
français mais d'après l'actualité on
constate bien qu'elle ne concerne pas
l'exécutif ce téléspectateur fait
évidemment allusion je pense à jean
castex qui était placé à l'isolément
qu'est ce que vous voulez lui répondre à
christoph c'est l'exécutif déjà il prône
surtout la vaccination complète la
troisième dose avec des tranches d'âge
qui le qui s'élargissent est il si
confus même si il le fait aussi pour une
haine donc l'essentiel le gouvernement
et les personnes responsables font c'est
de la vaccination après le problème moi
j'ai moi même remarqué depuis un certain
nombre de semaines et je m'en désole un
relâchement général des gestes barrières
au motif qu'on et d'actionner j'ai
participé ces trois derniers jours à
deux réunions avec 300 personnes dans
une salle où tout le monde était
démasqué je trouve ça pas normal parfois
on se masque pendant la réunion et la
réunion il ya un risque que le
gouvernement communique à ses justes
pour dire il faut pas abandonner
voyez bien quand vous êtes au contact on
a tous déjà on a tous envie de reprendre
une vie normale on arrête tous envie de
laisser tomber le masque de serrer la
main de se serrer dans les bras et c'est
bon et les ministres ils sont en contact
permanent tout au long de la journée
avec des tas de personnes ils ont ils
ont ils sont comme les autres
c'est-à-dire ils auront parfois aussi
ils n'ont pas forcément le masque il
serre la main parfois ils essaient de
checker moi je me suis trouvé dans une
réunion d'élus de mer où j'ai checké dix
fois j'ai abandonné au bout de dix fois
tout le monde me serrer la et quand je
tendais le point les gens de m'entourer
là le point avec la main j'ai fini par
serrer la main comme tout le monde donc
c'est très très difficile on a tous
envie de reprendre une vie normale et
puis tout le monde s'est relâché disons
le tout le monde s'est relâchée vous
constatez un brouillard man's vous vous
constatez ce relâchement bruno m'égare
ban on
ricane osé parler du vaccin qui est
important n'est perdu bruno meier bonne
alors on va repartir avec avec avec
alexis poulain vous êtes là
on a retrouvé bruno meyer ban on vous
entend c'est déjà ça
par rapport aux fleurs haut par rapport
je vous confirme tout à fait
effectivement il y à bien relâchement
des barrières partout dans la société
dans dans les entreprises ont des
réunions dans les casses dans les
restaurants et lieux de loisirs
malheureusement effectivement on a lu
à la suite
définitivement débat
ce n'est pas le cas nous l'avions déjà
signalé le virus ne disparaîtra pas de
la planète
maintenant c'est vrai que le baas nous
nous attendions comme étant plus
performant pour protéger contre des
nations s'est avérée un peu moins à ce
niveau est ce que vous attendez demain
du conseil de défense sanitaire jean luc
mélenchon aujourd'hui a tweeté vacciner
ne règle pas tout vous attendez par
exemple que les tests redeviennent
gratuit
alors nous espérons que un changement du
pass sanitaires et le pass vaccinale
avec peut-être
comme corollaire le remboursement à
nouveau des tests virologiques pour
permettre à tous de se dépister car on
voit aujourd'hui être contact devient
très fréquents je crois qu'il ya une
partie de la population qui a peur de
devoir débourser de l'argent pour ces
tests et qui malheureusement même
contact ne se dépistent pas et peut
contribuer à propager le virus par
ailleurs évidemment on attend on va dire
une annonce ou mieux encourager la
vaccination de personnes encore non
vaccinés et enfin très probablement
une extension
la population éligible
de 40 ans
justement c'était la question m'a tendu
la perche bonhomme avec mes gars ban la
haute autorité de santé on l'avait
également avec katia pique nique devant
le ministre de la santé préconise une
dose de rappel pour les plus de 40 ans
mais est ce que cette dose de rappel va
être élargi pour tous les adultes
sûrement vous c'est peut-être ce qui
peut être annoncé demain au conseil de
défense de communication que va dire le
gouvernement ben je pense oui puisque
apparemment on a suffisamment de doses 1
de peur au moins pour cette troisième
dose et qu'apparemment elle booste un
pour l'hiver au moins les défenses
immunitaires après sur le temps long on
verra comme pour les premières doses et
les deuxième dose ce qu'il en est sur le
long terme puisque on avance à vue en
réalité un seul vaccin on est en train
de découvrir qui marche moins bien que
ce qui avait été proposé ou annoncé un
parent fighters 95 % de d'efficacité
contre le virus on voit bien que
vacciner on attrape le coc vide on le
transmet également donc évidemment ça
commence à poser des questions alors on
fait des formes moins grave mais on voit
et qui fait plus il ya de vacciner plus
il ya de gens doublement vaccinés avec
un schéma complet qui se retrouve à
l'hôpital quand même donc ça pose la
question aussi de de cette efficacité
finalement et d'où la question des
gestes barrières on peut pas et la
communication du gouvernement c'est pour
ça qu'il ya un bug c'est que d'un côté
on a le premier ministre les ministres
qui expliquent doctement qu'il faut
respecter les gestes barrière y compris
à la maison les masques etc et puis on
voit les vidéos du chef de l'état à
faire la fête après le match de foot
caritatif embrassant tout le monde on
voit jean castex au salon des maires
pareil serrant la main de tout le monde
et les français ne comprennent pas ils
se disent alors attendez d'un côté on
doit faire obéir à des injonctions
contradictoires de l'autre côté ceux qui
nous imposent les confinements ce qui
nous impose des gestes barrières bien
finalement s'en fichent totalement et le
montre avec un grand sourire ça peut pas
fonctionner avec cette communication là
il ya un nouvel exemple par rapport à ça
je me tourne vers vous et un call aux
airs il ya aussi la clément bonin
secrétaire d'état
chargé des affaires européennes qui a
retiré sa photo d'instagram sur laquelle
il posait avec avec jean castex sans
masque c'est quoi c'est faites ce que je
dis ne faites pas ce que je fais comme
du vin je crois que la situation est
suffisamment inquiétante même si avec le
vaccin on peut être un petit peu rassuré
pour qu'on aille pas trop se perdre dans
les anecdotes pardon mais je crois que
l'essentiel c'est vraiment d'appeler nos
concitoyens avec les réserves vous avez
raison de dire que le bac c'est un petit
peu moins efficace que ce qu'on a dit il
reste toutefois très efficace il ya le
rapport est de 1 à 10 entre les
personnes dax idées et non vaccinés dans
les entrées en à l'hôpital et en soins
critiques en réanimation et avec la
troisième dose c'est même de 1 à 30 donc
il faut vraiment exhorté nos concitoyens
à aller se vacciner puisque vous êtes
dans l'anecdote j'ai entendu aussi le
cas de cette famille vosgienne où
aujourd'hui où les trois personnes non
vaccinées sont décédées trois personnes
dans un village de noyers quasiment
personne avec une comorbidité elle
rappelait aussi l'une des deux premières
très âgés donc par nature fragile et le
troisième est qu'une comme ermite coma
ou une comorbidité enfin malgré tout on
se dit mais quel gâchis alors qu'on a
qu'on a un vaccin quoi moi ça me fait de
la peine de voir tous ces gens qui sont
influencés par tous ceux qui à la
moindre occasion y compris la réflexion
vous avez apporté de jean luc mélenchon
l'instant à chaque occasion c'est
l'occasion de jeter le doute sur la
vaccination bien sûr que la vaccination
ne fait pas tout mais elle fait
l'essentiel il faut le dire et le redire
et des courbes sont claires quand on
compare les pays dans les pays les plus
vaccinée c'est là qu'on a le moins de
décès rapportés à la moyenne de
population bien entendu on l'a vu
d'ailleurs dans les territoires outre
mer et les îles du pacifique voilà donc
c'est clair et il faut pas que de doute
là dessus et est vraiment c'est des gens
les plus fragiles française mêlée
française pose quand même la question et
regardez par exemple nathalie leur comme
c'est faites ce que je dis faites pas ce
que je fais est normé personne est
infaillible et je voulais dis moi moi
moi même je pourtant je suis d'origine
même ne masque sur votre plateau
j'essaie d'avoir le trou sera possible
les distances mardi avant des mois et
même des moments je craque comme je vous
l'expliquais tout à l'heure quand tout
le monde même serré la main que je
prends toi est comme saisi maman qui
secoue les jeux face à beaune et j'ai
envie de masques et j'ai serré la main
et donc si on prend en photo à ce moment
là eh ben on va voir je serre la main
mais je crois pas que ça doit parce
qu'on est tous ces éléments là si on les
rabâchant boucle eh bien ça les gens les
qui sont les plus éloignés de la
formation qui sont souvent les plus
pauvres les plus isolés ils vont
entendre ces sons de cloches qui vont
dire regardez ils sont pas d'accord
entre eux mais beaucoup étaient attendus
sur la lune explication que il ya un tel
ras-le-bol une telle lassitude parce que
le vaccin était vendu comme la fin du
masque la fin des gestes barrières
rappelez-vous les mots de jean castex
qui disait si vous êtes doublement
vaccinez vous notre après palco vide bon
il est malade ce soir on lui souhaite un
bon rétablissement mais il ya eu
tellement de ratés dans la communication
c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois on
promettait une libération un retour à la
vie d'avant et aujourd'hui on a le
vaccin les gestes barrière le masque et
on sais pas qu'est ce qu'on va avoir
d'autres peut-être le retour un
confinement ce doit être un couvre-feu
c'est à dire que les français n'en
peuvent plus en réalité la cigm tout
fait pour s'en sortir et on n'en sort
pas ce que vous imaginez la situation
dans laquelle on serait si on n'avait
pas eu ce vaccin ce serait dramatique on
serait en confinement permanent
l'économie serait effondré il y aurait
des détresses psychologiques et sociales
ce serait terrible sur l'impact des
jeunes et des treize étudiants auxquels
sociales seraient les musées les
guerriers se seraient multipliés à
l'infini donc on a eu cette chance ils
espéraient d'abord al-aqsa et on peut
donner de l'espoir aux français on se
souvient à cette époque-là de l'année là
mais l'année dernière l'année dernière
il y avait trois sets et olivier ferrand
qui disait par rapport à la bûche de
noël on va devoir la manger peut-être à
distance ou quelque chose dans le civil
par rapport à la bûche de noël voyez
bien pouvoir semble reconnaissait que au
nom d'anne de l'information et de la
connaissance qui s'accumulent au fur et
à mesure du temps faire à mesure qu'on
constate ce qui se passe au début on ne
savait pas que le vaccin fonctionnerait
six mois on s'aime on se doutait qu'il
allait fonctionner qu un certain temps
on ne fait pas la dose de boutiques et
les gens qui demandaient un peu plus de
recul et on se dit maintenant regardez
il ya suffisamment de recul et on voit
bien que le recul on est en train de le
faire en annonçant 6 a demandé de recul
pour attendre de faire la vaccination
dire qu'il ya certains vaccins qui
maintenant sont déconseillés pour les
moins de 30 ans que j'en sois modern art
radical d'attitude les handicaps graves
d'abaisser les seuils sont non non non
ils sont suspendus pour les moyens
conseiller là sont attendus vous savez
on est revenu sur astrazeneca on
arrêtait astrazeneca au motif qu'ils
avaient des phlébites des yeux etc les
anglais ont vacciné toute leur
population avec astrazeneca oui avec
avec beaucoup n'avaient pas grave avec
pas plus de problèmes vasculaires
thromboemboliques que chez nous moi je
regrette qu'on arrêtait l'émotion était
telle qu'il fallait arrêter la
précaution nous a poussé à l'extrême de
l'arrêter malheureusement maintenant on
a fait des études avec le recul on sait
qu'il ya pas plus dans boullier
d'accidents cardiovasculaires c'est en
fait quelques-unes quand même
malheureusement oui il pas plus que dans
la population normale c'est ce
qu'avaient les cieux messieurs sont sur
le marché depuis plus longtemps mais non
non non
prendre forme et gardanne il est là et
il est là jusqu'en le professeur mais
guère ban vous avez peut-être envie de
réagir à ce qui vient de se dire là sur
le plateau
oui non je suis tout à fait d'accord ce
qui vient des ti effectivement si nous
avions pas le vaccin nous serions
aujourd'hui dans une situation
de gravité extrême lui quasiment aucune
activité sociale économique ou aurait pu
avoir lieu les écoles les universités
ont été fermées les hôpitaux ont été
submergés mais tout aurait été bien de
me regarde je me permet de redonner
encore cette anecdote un jean castex sq
a reçu deux doses de vaccin
mais il est positif le vaccin qui
protège le sait contre les quatre graves
on espère qu'il va bien se porter
évidemment mais il ya quand même pas un
petit peu démoralisant tout ça on se
vaccine on est quand même vacciner
c'est qu'on la fin de tout ça dans dix
ans comme disait par exemple votre
confrère jelly annan en début d'année
dernière je crois le chef de réanimation
à l'hôpital de garches
alors si vous voulez le virus existera
sur la planète il y aura toujours un
réservoir humain non immunisés mais
vacciner et surtout un réservoir animal
mais avec l'augmentation de l'immunité
collective de la population et bien au
fur et à mesure des contaminations
l'infection deviendra de plus en plus
mignonne et donc effectivement on va
assister très bientôt je ne sais pas
dans quel délai
parce que ce virus devient responsable
d'une maladie
respiratoire
banal hivernale mais en attendant il y a
encore exactement la moitié de la
planète qui n'est pas maxime et de ce
fait évidemment il ya une menace directe
pour justifier non vaccinés en faire des
formes graves de la maladie a empêché à
arras on va dire garantir la circulation
à haut niveau du virus et donc
malheureusement au risque d'émergence du
baril la commission européenne a tweeté
un tableau avec des données disant que
plus le taux de vaccination est élevé
plus la mortalité est faible eric
alauzet on le voit la ce ce tableau au
niveau de votre communication au sein de
votre parti présidentiel comment
convaincre justement les non vaccinés et
bien en projetant le tableau que vous
êtes vous même en train de projeter à
l'instant je sais pas s'il est visible
sur l'écran pour télévision blatter
c'est flagrant vous voyez bien à gauche
plus vous êtes en haut à gauche en bleu
plus vous êtes vacciné dans les pays et
en bas quand ça devient rouge très peu
vaccinés et vous avez à droite la
colonne alors je sais pas si c'est des
gens en hospitalisation en réanimation
je ne vois pas bien en tout cas on voit
bien que dans les pays non vaccinés en
bas à gauche fascine vers signer à
droite les morts et donc on voit bien
dans les pays peu vaccinés en bas de
l'échelle le nombre de morts a rapporté
à la même unité de population a sinon ça
voudrait rien dire voilà et bien vous
projetez ça faut mettre matin midi et
soir mais d'un autre côté il y aussi le
le côté on va dire liberticide entre
guillemets je vous propose de regarder
cette déclaration sur le conte
télégramme de berthet france delphine
qui dit prendre en otage les gens et
détruire la liberté ce n'est pas
communiqué alexis poulain non c'est pas
gouverner non plus c'est à dire que on a
vu une gestion extrêmement autoritaire
extrêmement sécuritaire la société de
vigilance c'est pas rien c'est la
vigilance de la technopolis on a vu la
loi sécurité globale qui était en même
temps que le vide derrière c'est pas du
tout des mesures sanitaires le fait que
les tests ne soient pas remboursés par
exemple c'est une mesure non sanitaires
j'attendais demain ce que le
gouvernement communique là dessus pour
rendre les tests gratuits une chose
importante est nécessaire je pense si on
veut être sérieux avec la limitation de
la propagation du virus et puis la
deuxième question qui se plaindrait ya
les finances la déception comment aussi
ça y est question la finance de toute
façon on trouve de l'argent magique
quand il ya besoin là là là dessus il
n'y a pas de problème donc vu qu'on est
en crise qu'on est en état d'urgence
permanent qu'on a une dette qu'ovide qui
est cataclysmique que le sénat vient de
retoquer de budget je pense qu'on peut
trouver de l'argent pour des tests mais
la question qui se pose fondamental
c'est celle du pass sanitaires si les
vaccinés sont contaminants et se
contaminent à quoi sert le pass
sanitaires à quoi sert le pass sanitaire
aujourd'hui puisque on a une population
vaccinée à plus de 76% chez les adultes
certaines tranches d'âge a plus de 80%
le pass sanitaire qui est son but sans
le dire c'était d'inciter les français à
la vaccination c'est fait mais après il
faut inciter à la troisième dose on va
garder le pass sanitaires pour la
quatrième dose également s'il faut une
quatrième dose tous les 6 mois comment
ça se passe le pass sanitaires
maintenant il n'a plus aucune raison
d'être alors soit on met un couvre-feu
on referme les lieux de sociabilité
comme les restaurants etc et on repart
dans ce délire là avec les commerces
sont essentiels soit on arrête souvent
dit voilà c'est fait c'est fait on a
réussi maintenant on va un peu lâché la
soupape parce que les français n'en
peuvent plus clairement le cas dans les
autres pays en voyant le verra un petit
peu plus tard
je dois me massou pas à payer non mais
si puisque en guadeloupe déjà ils ont
décalé l'obligation vaccinale des
soignants autres en terre et maintenant
les tests sont revenus des tests
gratuits sont revenus donc de toutes
façons vous voyez bien que si sa gueule
à un moment le gouvernement oblige et 10
rebonds on va arrêter avec nos mesure où
on enferme les hamsters dans la cage on
les fait sortir et c'est donc là je
crois que c'est important aussi de
comprendre que le sanitaire doit
redevenir au devant de la scène et le
sécurité à l'autoritaire doit laisser la
place voilà au sanitaire parce que sinon
ça ne tiendra pas sur le long terme
votre réaction est un calvaire sur votre
premier point des libertés sur lequel
vous avez eu une réaction impulsive moi
je considère que ce sont celles et ceux
qui ne se vaccinent pas qu'ils attentent
à la liberté de la société puisqu'il
nous retarde parfois de bonne foi je
certains ont peur et on pouvait discuter
tout ça mais en tout cas il nous retarde
par le fait qu'ils encore le cas ce % de
gens non vaccinées dans le processus d'
aller de retrouver une vie normale plus
en argent non vaccinés plus on risque d
confinement des des couvre-feux qui vont
atteindre les libertés de toutes
sortes 10% des îles avec cinéaste à plus
de 100% ou de toute façon reconfirme
quand toute la population française
vaccinée et qu'il y aura toujours le
virus fisc visible importance et il ne
s'agit pas du baratin et qui rend
confine et oui les histoires ils sont
obligés par 70% malheureusement l'écart
est un pays comme l'islande par exemple
qui est très vacciner où il ya beaucoup
de 4go vite n'y a pas de cas graves pour
gan confusion permanente qui est
entretenue entre le nombre de cas et le
nombre de cas graves si demain pour les
raisons qu'on a indiqué parce que le vu
le diable et militer collective etc on a
toujours vingt mille trente mille
cinquante mille cas mais que ce sont des
cas bénins déco vide est comme on a des
grippes est pour s'en fiche c'est pas le
cas actuellement c'est pas encore le cas
non ce n'est pas encore le cas mais on
va y aller progressivement versés mais
on a encore besoin pour l'instant de
deux voiliers alors le deuxième question
c'était le vaccin ne protège pas contre
la contamination on est content on peut
être contaminé les gros de ruminants on
est passé du noir au blanc les choses
sont grises en réalité on est passé le
mans on croyait on espérait que le
vaccin nous protégerait contre le fait
d'être contaminés contaminants ils nous
protègent contre les réanimations
cellule donc non et maintenant on va
dire le contraire le vaccin ne protège
pas contre la contamination
et le fait d'être contaminés et d'être
contaminant les basses et entre les deux
à ce moment la
cassure entre vaccinale vacciner avec la
troisième dose qui nous protège beaucoup
plus trente fois plus à utiliser 1 à 10
entre 1,1 et non vaccinés quelqu'un qui
avait de doses à 30 en train non
vaccinés quelqu'un qui a les 3-12
peut-être mais je m'avance donc on verra
peut-être que avec la troisième dose on
est peut-être encore un peu moins
contaminant est contaminée non mais
carbone vous pouvez peut-être réagi on
arrive à
point nommé vous avez beau temps va
peut-être écouter la parole d'ing
j'apprécie beaucoup je l'écouté souvent
sur est si votre chat conclu en tirant
tout cas je vais les écouter on sait
très bien aussi
je confirme tout à fait les propos de
monsieur le député il a tout à fait
raison effectivement heureusement que
nous avons le vaccin ne protège contre
les formes graves de la maladie
est effectivement lorsque des personnes
deviendront éligibles à cette troisième
dose en saurons très nettement leur
protection par un facteur au vin donc
c'est quelque chose d'essentiel
on peut même penser que cette protection
va durer beaucoup plus longtemps que six
mois
il est vrai aussi très probablement la
contamination va se réunir d'ailleurs on
voit aujourd'hui en israël avec la
stratégie de la troisième dose plus
générale à la populace man u vient dé
l'un des seuls pays occidentaux où
finalement les contaminations régressent
et c'est vrai que malheureusement on
devoir apprendre à vivre avec le virus à
condition évidemment que l'on soit pro b
g et à ce moment là il y aura pas de
problème cette ce virus sera
assimilables un virus responsable des
infections respiratoires ban a
d'ailleurs dû russes lointains et 4 au
dessus kooza coronavirus responsables de
tels problèmes merci pour votre votre
décryptage bruno médian ben je rappelle
que vous êtes le chef de réanimation de
l'hôpital lariboisière à paris merci
également à vous messieurs alexis
poulain éditorialistes arte france eric
alauzet député lrm du tout merci c'est
la crise sanitaire à l'origine des
violences urbaines aux antilles où la
situation reste tendue au lendemain
d'une règle très à matignon les forces
de l'ordre sont prises pour cibles le
gouvernement appelle au calme avant
d'entamer des négociations avec les
manifestants avec les manifestants quant
à mon père
après l'embrasement et le chaos le calme
la nuit est synonyme d' émeutes de
voitures brûlées et au lever du soleil
le mobilier urbain encombrent toujours
les routes des magasins gardent leur
rideau baissé depuis plus d'une semaine
la contestation contre l'obligation
vaccinale du personnel soignant a pris
une ampleur sans précédent et provoque
une importante crise sociale après jean
castex lundi c'est au tour du ministre d
outre-mer d'appeler au calme ce mardi
l'ordre républicain doit revenir le
ministre de l'intérieur a annoncé des
renforts importants pred gign puisque la
nuit ce sont malheureusement des forces
de l'ordre qui sont victimes de tirs à
balles réelles et 7 cela ne pouvons pas
l'accepter nous devons le condamner avec
force car la violence n'a pas sa place
sur le territoire de la république en
guadeloupe comme ailleurs ce mardi au
gosier un barrage filtrant a été mis en
place par les contestataires seul le
personnel soignant était autorisé à
poursuivre son chemin en martinique
également la colère gronde une grève
générale a commencé ce lundi à
l'initiative des organisations
syndicales plusieurs barrages bloquent
depuis ce mardi matin les principaux
axes routiers de l'île lundi des
centaines de martiniquais ont défilé
dans les rues de fort de france cet
appel à la mobilisation divise parmi la
population
nous soutenons
le leader syndical et contre le pass and
i ter et l'obligation vaccinale c'est un
élargissement du conflit c'est une grève
générale qui touche tous les secteurs
aujourd'hui en martinique les secteurs
d'activité et plus seulement le secteur
sanitaire et social moi je pense que
cette gomme général c'est une grève
inutile parce que le gouvernement a déjà
pris sa décision question de vaccination
déjà qu'il refuse à se fatiguer non je
ne pense pas au nom un résultat positif
au niveau du gouvernement en guadeloupe
comme en martinique les émeutes de nuit
ont donné lieu à des tirs à balles
réelles des manifestants en direction
des forces de l'ordre et des pompiers
jean castex annoncé ce lundi la création
d'une instance de dialogue avec les élus
mais la situation pourrait perdurer
selon maxime tracker 35 3% des
martiniquais ont déjà reçu une dose de
vaccin un pourcentage qui tombe à 34 %
chez les guadeloupéens
ailleurs en europe les pays-bas
transfèrent leurs premiers patients vers
des hôpitaux en allemagne les systèmes
hospitaliers néerlandais dont déjà en
souffrance l'allemagne ainsi que le
danemark qui sont d'ailleurs deux
destinations que les états unis à des
conseils aujourd'hui à leurs
ressortissants le point sur la situation
outre rhin avec peter oliver à berlin
pour arte un correspondant pour arte
internationale
un débat crucial a lieu en ce moment en
allemagne le pays doit-il suivre
l'exemple de l'autriche et rendre la
vaccination obligatoire cette mesure
entre en vigueur en autriche à partir du
1er février de l'année prochaine le
débat en allemagne porte surtout sur la
question de savoir si cette mesure est
légitime dans le cadre de la
constitution en vigueur d'autres mesures
ont déjà été prises dans certaines
régions allemandes notamment le
couvre-feu interdisant de sortir de chez
soi après 22 heures après l'état de
bavière l'état de saxe et d'autres
villes allemandes la ville de stuttgart
et la dernière nulle et les marchés de
noël pendant les fêtes hivernales angela
merkel a caractérisé cette nouvelle
vague de kovy 19 de pire que tout ce
qu'on a connu le ministre de la santé y
gagnent span lui a exposé sa vision des
choses et il est plutôt pessimiste
probablement à la fin de l'hiver comme
on le dit parfois avec cynisme chacun ou
presque en allemagne sera vacciné guéri
ou mort mais c'est vrai en raison de la
propagation du variant delta est très
très contagieux c'est fort probable
pendant ce temps l'autriche vie le
deuxième jour du nouveau confinement au
niveau national il durera au moins dix
jours et pourrait être prolongé jusqu'au
13 décembre
les gens là bas en autriche est ici en
allemagne expriment leur préoccupation
concernant les mesures prises par le
gouvernement en se demandant si elle
était bonne
je ne crois pas du tout que le
confinement s'achèvera dans trois
semaines même pour nous qui avons déjà
été vaccinées
c'est comme ça
c'est trop tard trop tard surtout la
vaccination obligatoire cette mesure
aurait dû être prise plus tôt mais pas
en février
compte apporter ces derniers mois on a
vu des vaccinations on a fait des tests
respecter la distanciation porter des
masques mais le nombre de cas qu vide
augmente malgré tout je ne pense pas que
ce soit bien d'abord ils ont dit que
tout allait s'ouvrir puis ils ont tous
construits finalement on nous dit qu'il
faudrait tous fermés et qu'on ne
pourrait rien ouvrir
en slovaquie et en république tchèque le
nombre de cas de covin ne cesse pas non
plus d'augmenter alors dans ces deux
pays des restrictions supplémentaires
ont été mises en place à partir de lundi
interdisant aux personnes non vaccinées
l'accès aux hôtels au bar au salon de
coiffure et à presque toutes les
réunions publiques car ils ont peur de
manquer de lits en soins intensifs
en raison du nombre important de
personnes touchées par le colis de 19
et l'armée allemande un compte rendre
obligatoire le vaccin anti qu'ovide pour
les soldats selon berlin ailleurs sur le
vieux continent les restrictions vont
bon train également tour d'horizon avec
thibaut jana
des restrictions partout en europe il y
encore quelques semaines cette hypothèse
était inenvisageable
désormais elle n'est plus exclu autriche
pays bas slovaquie belgique grèce et
même allemagne tous ces pays ont pris de
nouvelles mesures restrictives pour
tenter de freiner la flambée épidémique
des décisions qui visent en priorité les
non vaccinés dernier exemple en date la
slovaquie qui impose un confinement pour
ceux qui n'ont pas reçu une injection un
choix qui divise la population
à mon avis tous les magasins sauf ceux
qui sont essentiels devraient absolument
fermer avant noël
car les chiffres des cas positifs que
vite sont alarmants
un peu plus que ce confinement partiel
le gouvernement a proposé quelque chose
de pas commode une fois de plus ils ne
font qu en bété les gens en lettonie il
est désormais possible de mettre un
salarié non vaccinés en congé forcé non
payés pendant trois mois avant de le
licencier
l'allemagne elle aussi a décidé de
sanctionner les réfractaires au vaccin
depuis jeudi dernier une nouvelle règle
est appliquée liberté totale pour les
vacciner et les guérit restrictions pour
les non vaccinés et le ministre de la
santé se montre très dur dans ces propos
c'est une circonstance que nous écrivons
depuis des mois probablement d'ici la
fin de cet hiver à peu près tout le
monde en allemagne sera vacciné rétabli
ou morges c'est comme ça avec le variant
delta très contagieux c'est très
probable
et c'est pourquoi nous recommandons de
toute urgence la vaccination même la
première vaccination
une volonté vaccinale clairement affiché
est appuyé par l'union européenne
bruxelles envisage notamment d'améliorer
la situation des vaccinés en actualisant
le certificat qu'ovide 19 pour préserver
la mobilité un sujet qui sera l'un des
thèmes du prochain sommet européen des
16 et 17 décembre prochains en attendant
ces approches opposant les vaccinés au
non vaccinés risque un peu plus de
diviser les populations partout où de
nouvelles restrictions ont été annoncés
des manifestations ont éclaté certaines
ont même tourné à l'émeute comme à
bruxelles ou encore à rotterdam
il aura fallu attendre 3 ans et demi
pour que les négociations aboutissent le
parlement européen et les vingt-sept
s'accordent sur la réforme nouvelle de
la politique agricole commune les
eurodéputés ont adopté le texte tout à
l'heure à strasbourg plus axé sur
l'écologie que la précédente mais
de nombreux élus et agriculteurs de
troupes cette réforme pas assez
ambitieuse et la voit plutôt comme du
greenwashing giat lamy
la nouvelle pac s'appliquera donc à
partir de 2023 le parlement européen a
voté ce mardi en faveur de sa mise en
place une politique agricole commune
présentée comme remaniée axée davantage
sur l'environnement et le bien-être
animal
nous avons la possibilité d'accorder à
nos citoyens une politique agricole
commune forte qui contribuera aux trois
dimensions de la durabilité économique
sociale et environnementale
elle favorisera un secteur agricole
durable et compétitif capable de
soutenir les moyens de subsistance des
agriculteurs et de fournir à la société
une alimentation saine et durable
soutenable faute 387 milliards d'euros
ils seront donc alloués jusqu'en 2027
dont 270 milliards consacrés aux aides
directes pour les agriculteurs un budget
conséquent puisqu'il représente un tiers
du budget pluriannuel européen des
primes sont également prévues pour les
agriculteurs utilisant des techniques
écologiques plus exigeantes que celles
répandu à l'heure actuelle ou qui
contribuerait à améliorer le bien-être
animal ces aides appelées échos régime
les vingt-sept devront y consacrer en
moyenne 25% par an de leurs paiements
directs chaque état doit maintenant
d'ici la fin de l'année préparer sa
stratégie d'utilisation de ces fonds
européens
mais cette nouvelle pac ne fait pas
l'unanimité auprès de certains élus et
agriculteurs
le parlement européen vient de se
coucher devant les lobbys en validant
cette pac de la honte j'ai voté contre
ce statu quo au criminel validant un
système agricole productiviste injuste
et dangereux qui malmènent les paysans
le climat et les animaux aujourd'hui le
parlement européen grade son rendez vous
avec l'histoire est valide cette réforme
de la pac anti paysans anti climat anti
biodiversité et anti europe au delà de
la politique agricole une question reste
en suspens celle du mal être des
agriculteurs
ce mardi le gouvernement à présenter des
mesures visant à améliorer
l'accompagnement des exploitants
détresse une mobilisation collective qui
comprend un budget plus conséquent pour
le remplacement des professionnels
épuisés ou encore la formation de
sentinelles chargé de détecter les
paysans en danger et en direct ce soir
pour évoquer le mal être des
agriculteurs tristan arlon secrétaire
général de l'association allo agri
délégués de la coordination rurale des
bouches du rhône bonsoir tristan à arlon
merci de répondre à nos questions sur
arte france la pac adopté aujourd'hui en
parallèle le gouvernement et qui lance
donc une mobilisation collective contre
les suicides d'agriculteurs dans quel
état d'esprit vous êtes avec toutes ses
actualités qui se bousculent aujourd'hui
pour les agriculteurs
va écouter au niveau du mal-être
agricole on est content que le
gouvernement prenne enfin ses
responsabilités
en revanche on sera très vigilant parce
qu'on se rend bien compte que ce sont
les politiques publiques en général qui
pousse le monde agricole vers la
détresse
l'enveloppent dédié au mal-être passe de
32 à 42 millions d'euros par an la
france qui reste six premiers
bénéficiaires au niveau de la politique
agricole commune ça va dans le bon sens
quand même non
oui ça va dans le bon sens ensuite nous
ce qu'on veut c'est des politiques
publiques efficaces parce que mais du
budget sur des politiques publiques ne
fonctionnent pas c'est encore donner de
l'argent à des structures qui
keane qui ne remplissent pas leur rôle
quoi alors qu'est ce qui est efficace et
qu'est ce qui n'est pas efficace
et côté aujourd'hui on a un gros souci
c'est que les personnes en détresse sont
souvent
malmené par la msa qui vient chercher
des cotisations salariales ou
professionnels et ensuite c'est la msa
qui va qu'est censé gérer le mal-être
agricole donc il ya il faut arriver à
scinder ces deux rôles hainaut ce qu'on
préconise c'est que l'ensemble de la pro
d2 la profession agricole se regroupent
et par exemple à la coordination rurale
on a créé une
éducation qui s'appelle aloha gris et
qui va
de manière prédictive
cibler les agriculteurs les plus en
danger en fait justement des
agriculteurs en danger autour de vous
vous en connaissez
côté oui j'en argent connais moi-même
j'ai lu j'ai subi énormément de pression
dans cette profession agricole donc on
sait exactement de quoi on parle et ça
se traduit par quoi
bein ça se traduit en fait c'est le
malaise agricole cetc
pluridimensionnelle donc une partie
économique évidemment on travaille
énormément l'indigo des recharges quand
on investit c'était grosses sommes donc
forcément une grosse pression mais
ensuite il ya les contrôles il ya
les risques qu'on prend au quotidien il
ya une ambiance qui est quand même assez
tendue dans le monde agricole et quand
on met tous route à bout effectivement
c'est pas une profession qui est simple
justement vous dites on s'endette pour
devenir plus gros a beaucoup disent que
l'agriculture nos jours encourage les
grosses exploitations au détriment des
plus petites notamment d'ailleurs la
politique agricole commune on dit
souvent que 80% de l'envelope pr bientôt
plus gros 20% aux plus petits comment
revenir à quelque chose de plus
raisonnable tout en n'oubliant pas le
consommateur non plus qu'il veut de plus
en plus bien manger
coûte et dont la coordination rurale on
défend l'agriculture familiale donc
c'est un modèle qui est assez simple la
cdc des structures moyennes de la
qualité du savoir-faire français
s'est relancé
la production française via le manger
français donc nous c'est un modèle qui
est assez simple un je pense que la
plupart des codes sont matters veulent
ensuite on voit bien que la politique
agricole qui est réellement mener c'est
pas du tout celle là on dit plutôt
inverse quand vous dites manger français
ça veut dire que vous dénoncez tous les
les pactes à l'international toutes les
alliances et ça et les importations par
exemple le fait de d'exporter des pommes
de terre et d'importer des chips c'est
quelque chose qui est antinomique
bien sûr et puis c'est surtout qu en
fait en france on est à peine en
autonomie alimentaire
c'est à dire que si on continue à moi
vous produire ça veut dire qu'on va
devenir dépendants les autres pays pour
se nourrir ce qui est parce que ce qui
est au niveau d'une stratégie
au niveau d'un état c'est extrêmement
c'est extrêmement dangereux donc nous ce
qu'on demande c'est un
relancer la production française et la
protéger dire que quand vous faites du
dumping social du dumping
environnemental avec des normes qui sont
différents d'un pays à l'autre au sein
de l'union européenne je parle même pas
de l'international hors union européenne
ont donc été déjà en europe on a des
problèmes de normes qui sont énormes en
fait donc rien que là il ya un vrai
travail et c'est pas normal que la
banque ne le prennent pas en
considération
moi justement par rapport à cette pac
les verts et une partie de la gauche
estime que le texte ne va pas assez loin
les agriculteurs dénoncent en grande
majorité du greenwashing pourtant les
pme reparti pour sept ans ou presque
oui on voit le résultat ça fait
en plus moi je suis agriculteur je suis
en bio donc je peux vous dire
les noces qu'on attend c'est des
politiques de développement de
l'agriculture
ces politiques de soutien c'est
ça n'a pas d'avenir en fait on vous
voulez pas de rafistolage mais vous
voulez plutôt aller sur l'avenir c'est
ça exactement il le gouvernement ça fait
cinq ans qu'ils doivent développer des
projets alimentaire territoriaux je
pense que ça parle aux gens c'est pour
rapprocher les producteurs locaux et
français de la population et de la
restauration collective pour faire très
simple
non on a beaucoup misé là dessus et en
fait on voit qu'il n'ya il ya quasiment
aucun projet qui émerge concrètement sur
les territoires
donc là on voit bien qu'à une heure il
ya un doublé 6 mai à quoi c'est à dire
que
c'est dû au fait que 1 selon nous il n'y
a pas de réelle volonté politique
c'est à dire qu'on va on va rester moi
je suis dans les bouches du rhône des
bouches du rhône on a 15 % d'autonomie
alimentaire sur le territoire 15% donc
en toute logique si vous développez
d'agriculture locale dans un bassin de
population qui est aussi fortement
peuplées vous ne pouvez pas avoir de
problème économique c'est impossible il
elle demande que c'est impossible et
pourtant il ya je crois il ya une
installation d'agriculteurs pour trois
départs à la retraite dans notre
département
donc c'est bien qu'il ya pas de
politique publique
merci à tristan arlon d'avoir répondu à
nos questions
merci très bonne soirée à vous merci
vous aussi
les états unis puisent dans leurs
réserves stratégiques de pétrole en
coordination avec d'autres pays
annoncent cet après midi de la maison
blanche objectif tenter de faire baisser
le prix de l'or noir en mettant 50
millions de barils sur le marché on en
parle tout de suite avec notre
correspondant à washington thomas bonnin
thomas comment la maison blanche
justifie cette décision
est bien joe biden vient de prononcer un
discours à l'instant où il a parlé d'une
initiative majeure qui pourra faire la
différence la maison blanche elle répète
depuis cette annonce qu'elle veut
utiliser tous les outils en sa
possession pour tenter de faire baisser
les prix c'est donc pour cette décision
pour cette situation qui a poussé le
président à puiser dans les réserves
stratégiques américaines de pétrole
c'est assez rare c'est presque même
inédit il ya eu donc une coopération
avec des pays tels que le royaume uni
l'inde ou encore le japon pour là encore
tenter de faire baisser le prix du
pétrole sur les marchés financiers mais
de l'avis de certains spécialistes cette
manoeuvre simultanée n'aura qu'un effet
à court terme et c'est aussi ce que
dénonce une partie de l'opposition
républicaine à dubaï d'un écouter
la décision du président byden de puiser
dans les réserves stratégiques
américaines ce qui va libérer seulement
l'équivalent de trois jours de pétrole
sur le marché n'est pas une véritable
solution à notre crise énergétique
c'est une ruse politique grossière à
trois jours de thanksgiving les élus
républicains qui reproche plus
généralement à joe biden sa politique en
matière d'énergie
accuse notamment les présidents
américains d'être finalement responsable
de la situation actuelle
il faut noter aussi que du côté
démocrate une lettre avait été adressée
ces derniers jours à destination du
président joe biden pour d'une part lui
demande et donc de puiser dans les
réserves stratégiques américaines de
pétrole mais aussi pour mettre un terme
au moins temporairement aux exportations
de pétrole américains c'est une mesure
qui n'a pour l'heure pas été retenu par
les services de la maison blanche et
thomas cette décision elle semble
également aller à l'encontre des
promesses du président américain en
matière de dérèglements climatiques là
encore comment se justifier le président
joe biden
et bien joe biden tente de se défendre
en parlant notamment des plans
d'investissement pour la lutte contre
les dérèglements climatiques qu'il est
en train de faire adopter au congrès
américain y compris dans le communiqué
qui a été publié par la maison blanche
pour annoncer donc cette décision de
libérer cinquante millions de barils sur
les marchés il est expliqué que malgré
ces mesures d'urgence joe biden reste
pleinement engagé pour ses promesses en
matière de transition énergétique alors
joe biden avait reconnu il ya quelques
semaines est lui même l'ironie de la
situation au moment de ces annonces de
ses promesses à la coop 26 à glasgow à
ce moment là ils demandaient déjà à
l'opep d'augmenter la production
mondiale de pétrole mais en fait joe
banner est en quelque sorte obligé
d'agir sur le sujet car l'augmentation
du prix à la pompe est un sujet de
préoccupation majeur pour les américains
dans un pays où la voiture est
évidemment très important joe biden qui
est déjà à la peine dans les sondages
notamment sur l'économie où c'est un
volet où il est très critiqué par les
américains en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
peut lire dans les différents sondages
et pour finir la preuve que cette
transition énergétique aux états unis
risquent d'être assez compliqué la
secrétaire d'état chargé de l'énergie a
été très vivement critiqué pour avoir
affirmé que cette hausse des prix de
l'essence était lié finalement à cette
transition énergétique une énième preuve
que la volonté de joe biden de réduire
l'impact environnemental des états unis
risquent bien souvent de se heurter à la
réalité du pays merci thomas bonnet pour
toutes ces précisions en direct de
washington
et selon le pentagone le chef d'état
major s'est entretenu par téléphone tout
à l'heure avec son homologue russe et ce
alors que les services de renseignement
extérieurs de la russie viennent de
prendre la parole en pleine escalade des
tensions sur le dossier ukrainien moscou
juge absolument fausses les affirmations
selon lesquelles le kremlin préparerait
une invasion de l'ukraine la
correspondance de maylis testerait
mensongère c'est ainsi que le service
russe de renseignement extérieur a
qualifié ce lundi les informations
fournies par le département d'état
américain
il affirme que la russie mobiliserait
des troupes sur son territoire dans le
but d'envahir l'ukraine le svr estime
que washington attend un signe d'affoler
la communauté internationale en agitant
une prétendue menace russe ces
accusations ont été reprise par de
nombreux médias occidentaux
d'après certaines informations le
département d'état américain par la voie
diplomatique communique des informations
totalement fausses sur la concentration
de troupes sur notre territoire en vue
d'une invasion militaire en ukraine nous
sommes inquiets qu'une telle propagande
agressive pousse le régime de kiev a
augmenté ses effectifs militaires dans
le dombass à renouveler des tirs
d'artillerie sur des sites civils le
service russe de renseignement extérieur
reprochent aux états unis et à l'union
européenne une politique provocatrice
qui je cite renforce délibérément le
sentiment de permissivité et d'impunité
de kiev le porte parole de vladimir
poutine a également réagi ce lundi aux
déclarations américaines en affirmant
que les mouvements de troupes russes en
russie n'en représentait de menace pour
personne pour rappel le secrétaire
d'état américain anthony blinken avait
déclaré ce samedi que les états unis
était sérieusement préoccupé par les
activités militaires inhabituel de la
russie à la frontière avec l'ukraine
ajoutant que ces inquiétudes étaient
largement partagé par les alliés de
washington est resté sur rtl france dans
quelques instants zoom sur les
révélations de disclose à d'après le
site d'investigation l'egypte
détournerait des renseignements
antiterroriste fournies par la france
pour traquer et tuer les trafiquants
présumés dont des civils pas tout de
suite
on a tous pensé qu'on descendait du
singe vous avez brisé ce tabou dans une
certaine mesure tout genre dont deux
singes le malheur c'est que quand on dit
descente des sages
on a l'impression qu'on descend des
chimpanzés et pas du tout les chimpanzés
et nous sommes cousins germains
maternelle qui était bretonne me disais
si toi tu descends du sage mois sur
europe 1 a révélé nous un secret vous en
avez mangé du mammouth je me trouve à
fouiller en sibérie et puis un beau
matin dans le trou que j'avais commencé
à creuser je trouve que les troupes
comme ce quelque chose de bien les
grands filaments je suis étonnée je râle
je dirais que ce sont des collègues
russes qui sont venus tripatouiller le
fond de ma recherche et puis à force de
tirer dessus comme rien ne venait je me
suis aperçu que j'étais sur le dos tu as
mammouth
[Musique]
le continent compte bien sûr quelques
femmes présidentes à son actif mais
souvent à titre symbolique à fiat et
bamba lamine vous êtes une femme
politique est ce que votre parcours a
été semé d'embûches entre les six que
voilà vous êtes là vous pour l
avoir les idées quand on regarde les
chiffres sur 255 députés n'ont que vingt
neuf ans les femmes ferait mieux que les
hommes dans le domaine de l'éveil
démocratique lorsque les femmes sont de
plus en plus prises en compte dans
l'échiquier politique
ça traduit généralement un éveil des
consciences un éveil politique qui
bénéficie à la population d'une manière
générale l'évolution des femmes en
politique ça ne doit pas être qu'une
idée ça va elle aussi un engagement que
le président
il
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
et
y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la table
c'était une volonté collective vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sent du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï tg les gens
ne s'étaient des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer qu une
sixième république qui ne soit pas
d'oubli parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct il y a
quand même la liberté je vous remercie
de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions des procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux et de
aidé de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter
les faits ni sur la liste des morts nés
sur imdb sécurité hopitalisés il était
nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane et en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur est la
couleur seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
de retour sur rt france il est 21h très
heureux de vous retrouver pour la
deuxième partie d'émission au sommaire
les révélations de 10 clos selon le
média d'investigation l'egypte
détournerait des renseignements
antiterroriste fournies par la france
pour traquer et tuer des trafiquants
présumés dont des civils journal en
ligne publie des documents explicite de
la direction du service du renseignement
militaire pas de réaction du quai
d'orsay alors que le site de 10 klose
n'est plus accessible au caire
[Musique]
une enquête en deux temps l'une
actuellement sur le site du média
disclose puis jeudi dans l'émission
complément d'enquêté sur france 2
l'investigation met en cause les
services français paris aurait fourni
des renseignements antiterroriste à
l'egypte une collaboration qui visait à
l'origine à
lutter contre le terrorisme mais qui
aurait été donc détourné par le caire
pour cibler des trafiquants et des
civils explications en images
[Musique]
où
et
l'egypte est un partenaire de la france
avec lequel nous entretenons des
relations dans le domaine du
renseignement et de la lutte
antiterroriste
pour des raisons évidentes de sécurité
et d'efficacité nous ne communiquerons
pas davantage sur la nature des
dispositifs de coopération mise en
oeuvre dans ce domaine
[Musique]
il
géopolitique ventes d'armes
renseignements on en parle tout de suite
dans le décryptage
[Musique]
et sur ce plateau à régis le sommier
bonsoir bonsoir et grand reporter arte
france et en direct de paris bastien
lachaud député la france insoumise de
seine-saint-denis bonsoir
bonsoir je commence avec vous abbas et
un à chaud puisque sur le site de la
france insoumise je cite les révélations
de disclose exige des explications
qu'est ce que vous demandez à exactement
une enquête parlementaire
nous demandons en effet une enquête
parlementaire nous demandons que toute
la lumière soit faite sur ces sur ces
faits qui s'ils étaient confirmés et
avérés sont une particulière gravité
il met en jeu l'honneur de la france est
en cause les plus hauts responsables du
pays qu'il s'agisse de deux présidents
de la république françois hollande et
emmanuel macron qu'il s'agisse du
ministre de la défense des manuels
macron aujourd'hui ministre des affaires
étrangères le jean yves le drian mais
également la ministre de désarmer
florence parly ces personnes doivent
s'expliquer sur le sur les notes qui qui
ont été rédigées à leur intention et a
priori des notes dont ils n'ont pas tiré
toutes les toutes les justes
conséquences régis le sommier pas encore
de réaction de la part du quai d'orsay
pourquoi d'après vous le ministère des
affaires étrangères attend le deuxième
volet de cette enquête jeudi soir ou
bien tout simplement paris ne veut pas
froisser
l'egypte pour garder de bonnes relations
avec un pays qui vient d'acheter la
semaine dernière 30 rafale alors il ya
des éléments qui laissent penser un peu
oui on m'attend tous de savoir un petit
peu la
deuxième partie et puis
vous l'avez cité le commet l'en quête de
complément d enquête jeudi soir le fait
que le site disclose a été mon
interrompue sur l'egypte est aussi une
indication que les égyptiens ne voit pas
la chose d'une d'une façon je dirais
très réjouissante
oui la france a des relations
extrêmement particulière avec l'egypte
l'egypte est une dictature l'egypte est
un pays dans lequel on enferme les
opposants mais l'egypte est un
partenaire au niveau des armes très
important vous l'avez souligné la
signature de ce contrat d'armement de 30
rafale qui est deuxième volet la
deuxième qu'il y avait eu 24 à falcon
était acheté précédent bien sûr que
précédemment il faut le rappeler en 2015
il faut rappeler quelle était
l'importance de ce contrat en 2015 il
s'agissait du premier contrat signé à
l'époque négocié par le drian et que
marc et celle ci six sous donc le ler de
françois hollande et à cette époque là
c'était le début de la vente de nos
rafale je savais qu'on avait eu
énormément de problèmes allaient aller
vendre à l'étranger et l'egypte avait
été une première à une première victoire
commerciale ensuite il y en a eu
d'autres avec le qatar les émirats
l'inde et il y avait tout un tas de pays
la grèce récemment donc si vous voulez
les jt un peu ouvert la voie pour la
fourniture de matériels dont 2/2 d'avion
aérien et par la suite aussi a eu
d'autres coopérations donc le problème
le problème c'est le détournement par
l'egypte ce qu indique cette enquête
deux technologies qui sont théoriquement
dédiée à la lutte antiterroriste ce
qu'on veut ce qu'ont fait les français
en justement contractant avec la la drm
donc la direction du renseignement
militaire
1 comment un partenaire luxembourgeois
une société la société cae qui a fourni
cet avion cet avion de surveillance
aérienne c'est que cet avion il était
censé surveiller des pick up de
terroristes dans le désert or le
problème c'est que dans la zone imparti
à la surveillance en général c'est du
trafic zen proche de la libye voilà ce
qu'on appelle du trafic
comment de bédouins en fait finalement
c'est de l'essence c'est des cigarettes
ça va être des produits de maquillage ça
peut être tout un tas de trafiquants
mais ce sont des civils oui mais ce sont
des civils oui exactement hélas la
présence de deux groupes jihadistes dans
cette zone là est assez faible elle a
été plus importante par le passé mais
aujourd'hui elle l'est pas est ce qui
peut expliquer l'embarras aussi de du
quai d'orsay et du ministère de la
défense la sueur ça c'est que cette
opération baptisée siri est
officiellement toujours en cours et
certainement justement bastien la chaux
il ya toujours selon le site disclose
dix militaires français qui seraient sur
place déployant en egypte dans cette
mission syrie qu'est ce que vous
demandez leur rapatriement
égouttez nous demandons déjà des
explications parce que le ce que ce qui
vient d'être dit est tout à fait juste
c'est à dire que nos si les faits sont
avérés nos moyens militaires ont servi à
des opérations de police qui n'ont rien
à voir avec la lutte contre le
terrorisme et donc ils ont été
totalement détournées de leur objectif
est à partir de ce moment là cette
opération aurait dû être
arrêté cette opération aurait dû être
arrêtée dès la première frappe constaté
des autorités égyptiennes sur des civils
suite à nos transferts d'informations et
de renseignements le
ni n'importe quel ministre
cohérent et appliquant réellement c'est
sa fonction avec honneur remplissant
avec ses fonctions avec honneur aurait
dû démissionner ou auraient dû faire
cesser
ces actes donc ces militaires qui ont
alerté il faut quand même le dire
ce sont les notes qui ont été publiés
par des jolies ce sont des notes de
militaires français qui disent attention
ce que nous faisons conduit à des à des
frappes sur des sur des civils prenez
des décisions les autorités politiques
n'ont pas agi ce sont les autorités
politiques qui aujourd'hui sont en cause
donc évidemment si les faits sont avérés
les militaires français doivent
immédiatement être rapatriés vous voulez
vendre d'armes à l'egypte doivent cesser
il n'est pas possible de fournir des
armes de fournir des équipements voire
des équipements mixte duale civile
militaire qui pourrait servir à la
répression de la population égyptienne
par un régime totalitaire qui ne
respectent absolument pas les droits de
l'homme et aujourd'hui nous nous battons
parlementaires français pour la
libération de prisonniers politiques en
egypte et dans le même temps nous avons
un exécutif qui continue de vendre des
armes et ses armes on s'en rend compte
aujourd'hui si les faits sont avérés
servent à frapper des civils servent
également à vitrac et via les réseaux
téléphoniques via les réseaux numériques
et cela conduit à des arrestations
de cibler deux opposants politiques si
jamais ces ventes d'armes sont et
l'équipement sont responsables de cela
il faudra que des personnes rendent des
comptes qu'il s'agisse des industriels
qu'il s'agisse des ministres qui ont
autorisé ses ventes régis donc l'egypte
l'un des partenaires de la france
commercialement parlant on l'a compris
au niveau des ventes d'armes le
président égyptien abdel fattah al-sisi
a même reçu la grand croix de la légion
d'honneur des mains des manuels macron
c'était en 2020 c'est en catimini à
l'écart de la presse française oui parce
que déjà la visite on s'en souvient en
2020 et posé une polémique aussi sur ses
rapports et toujours cette situation
particulière que la france et de ses
relations particulières que la france
entretient avec l'egypte il faut dire
que dans la région l'egypte c'est fait
et quand même un pays instable que la
france a des intérêts puis il ya la
question de la crise libyenne qui n'est
pas fini aux portes et que l'égypte
évidemment un poids énorme dans cette
dans le déroulement de ce qui se passe
en libye actuellement notamment via
l'appui qu'elle a quel hacker lequel
l'offre au général haftar donc on est
dans de la géopolitique on n'est pas
dans du sentimental le problème de la
france c'est qu'elle veut toujours jouer
sur les deux tableaux quand j'arrive le
drian reggae récemment dans le monde que
nos concurrents en parlant de la chine
et la russie n'ont aucune aucun tabou et
aucune limite on s'aperçoit que si ces
faits là sont avérées non plus n'avons
pas non plus beaucoup de limites quand
il s'agit de défendre nos intérêts mais
ça c'est le cas de tout le monde et
après il faut pas vouloir comment tenir
des propos en jouant les plus vertueux
c'est la réalité et la réalité des
relations alors après est-ce que ça pose
sur la question des civils ça c'était je
le rappelle déjà posé sur la question en
mai 2019 lorsque deux des fondateurs
d'ailleurs du site disclose avait été
entendu par la dgse parce que il avait
fait une enquête avait conduit une
enquête justement sur la nature de la
discorde le fameux ariane boulle à paris
qui avait créé des armes des arbres la
destination d'arabie saoudite pour pour
selon le site frappé notamment des
civils au yémen exactement vous l'avez
résumé mais 7,7 à l'époque c'était quand
même
une question importante en relief
florence parly était monté au créneau
expliquant que ces armes n'avaient pas
été utilisés en réalité en fait il
s'avère qu'elle aurait été utilisée dans
une guerre qui il faut le rappeler
aujourd'hui l'épreuve les prochaines les
estimations de l'onu pour la fin 2021 la
guerre au yémen ces trois cent mille
morts et donc si ça veut dire que les
armes françaises ont été utilisés aussi
dans ses cadres l'a donc à chaque fois
c'est un c'est toujours le problème de
la vente d'armes mais le problème des
ventes d'armes on vous dira aussi que
ces deux cent mille emplois en francs à
l'appartement je l'admiré et la perche
sur la question d'une normalisation
la shoah par rapport à ça puisque la
france est 3e ou 4e exportateur de vente
d'armes dans le monde justement vous
comprenez cet argument que vient de de
stipuler régis le sommier l'argument
industriel vendre moins d'armes à
l'egypte ou à l'arabie saoudite s'est
également peut-être perdre des emplois
en france
c'est un véritable problème que toute
notre économie de défense soit basée sur
l'exportation d'armes parce que
justement à partir du moment où nous
basons notre économie de défense sur
l'exportation d'armes eh bien nous
sommes prêts à toutes les compromissions
pour vendre des armes la réalité c'est
que aujourd'hui nos armées ont dit
besoin d'armements qui satisferait
pleinement le carnet de commandes des
industriels parce que les rafales c'est
intéressant de voir si rafale qui sont
achetés la plupart des rafa qui sont
achetés par des contrats en ce moment
sont des rafales d'occasions c'est à
dire que des pays achètent des rafales
qui sont utilisés par l'armée de l'air
française
et l'armée de la française est obligé de
racheter des rafale à dassault pendant
et donc au final ça coûte de l'argent à
l'armée française pendant quelques mois
pendant quelques années nous allons être
sous dotées en rafale voire même on
parle de nous racheter des mirage 2000
pour réside pour tenir le coup par
rapport à ces rafales qui vont partir à
l'export mais au final on se retrouve
avec une armée française qui était
poussé ces deux ci moyens pour pouvoir
vendre donc on marche sur la tête il
faut en finir avec ce système économique
où nous sommes dépendants de l'exploit
les les armées françaises besoin
équipements fournissons aux armées
françaises des besoins en équipements je
suis sûr que nous remplissons les
carnets de commandes de nos industriels
nous n'avons pas besoin de l'export il
s'agit là de renverser le
renverser le système de économique sur
lequel est basé notre économie défense
mais en tout cas ce qui est certain
c'est qu'à partir du moment où nous
avons une économie de défense qui est
basée sur l'exportation et bien en effet
nous sommes prêts à toutes les
compromissions pour exporter à tout prix
y compris mettre en difficulté nos
armées en et des peu semblent les
équipements dont ils ont dont l oms dont
elles ont besoin il faut aujourd'hui en
finir avec ça il faut évidemment
nationaliser les industries de défense
parce que construire des armes vendre
des armes ce n'est pas une activité
anodine ce n'est pas une activité comme
les autres et nous le voyons aujourd'hui
donc il faut en revenir au système qui
était en place en france dans les années
1980 ou même d'assaut avaient été
nationalisées et d'assaut de ce n'était
pas plus mal portée que qu'aujourd'hui
donc tout ça c'est ce que nous portons
dans l'avenir en commun avec jean luc
mélenchon au niveau de la france
insoumise et c'est aujourd'hui quelque
chose qui serait nécessaire et utile
pour en finir avec ces scandales à
répétition qui met en jeu l'honneur de
la france qui met en jeu sa réputation
qui met en jeu sa capacité à agir pour
le niveau international
le mot de la fin régis le sommier le mot
de la fin je pense qu'on le verra dans
complément d'enquêté jeudi parce qu'on a
quand même hâte de voir un petit peu ce
qu'il ya en plus et le l'enquète
complète puisqu'elle est pas encore l ai
pas encore établi les faits bon ce qu'on
a vu c'est effectivement une frappe du
21 septembre 2016 où on voit effet
l'avons n'atteste ou là les documents
attestent de la présence d'un cessna
armée l'armée égyptienne dans une zone
est ensuite d'un certain nombre de
pick-up détruits donc ça voilà il ya
effectivement mais y aurait eu plusieurs
dizaines de frappe de mai du même ans
donc il faut voir un peu l'ampleur
de cette utilisation des renseignements
ces programmes ont rappelé que ce sont
pas les français qui frappe directement
des cibles que l'unc indiquerait
l'egypte mais qu'il s'agit justement de
renseignements apportés par ce programme
l'aéronef voilà et que la donc à établir
un petit peu l'exactitude de ce qui
s'est passé depuis combien de temps dure
ce programme a priori depuis le 13
février 2016 mais sous françois hollande
et y est il toujours opérant fourni ton
toujours c'est ces informations et s'il
s'avère qu'elles ont dépassé le cadre du
simple finalement de la lutte contre le
terrorisme puisque c'est là dessus
qu'ils emmanuel macron et comment le
pari shell scission on re réaffirmé leur
partenariat récemment et bien il ya
vraiment un problème mais là il faut il
faudra qu'ils éthique et qui vaut moins
explications et et peut-être suspension
de ce genre de pratiques merci régis le
sommier d'avoir à demander à nos
questions vous êtes grand reporter pour
arte france merci également à 21 h au
d'être intervenue ce soir vous êtes
député elle fit en seine saint denis
pays frontalier de l'egypte la libye ou
98 candidat souhaite présenter à la
présidentielle le 24 décembre le dépôt
des candidatures s'est achevé hier la
haute commission nationale électorale à
12 jours pour valider les dossiers parmi
les prétendants l'un des fils de
mouammar kadhafi le marché naftal qui
contrôle une partie du pays ou encore le
chef du gouvernement intérimaire quentin
voeckler
deux semaines après l'ouverture du dépôt
des candidatures
les dossiers se sont multipliés à la
haute commission nationale électorale
parmi les principaux prétendants à la
présidence le premier ministre
intérimaire en poste depuis février
dernier
rejoignez
mon peuple mes frères ma famille malgré
toutes les difficultés et les
circonstances ambigu qui ont accompagné
le parcours électoral je vous invite à
ne jamais perdre espoir car il est
devenu clair et de toute évidence le
début du bon chemin
la candidature de l'actuel premier
ministre réputé proche de la turquie et
des frères musulmans a de quoi
surprendre lors des négociations avec
l'onu pour la bonne transition du pays
abdelhamid pays bas avait promis qu'il
ne serait pas candidat la loi électorale
lui impose de suspendre ses fonctions
trois mois avant l'élection en cas de
candidature autre prétendant parmi les
grands noms du scrutin le maréchal
haftar ancien commandant de l'armée
nationale libyenne
soutenu par l'egypte par l'arabie
saoudite et un temps par la france
khalifa haftar est accusé par certains
candidats de vouloir rétablir une
dictature en 2019 il avait déjà essayé
de prendre le pouvoir par la force
la semaine dernière le maréchal a appelé
les libyens à se mobiliser massivement
lors de ce scrutin qu'ils considèrent
comme la seule chance pour le pays de
sortir du chaos
l'étape à venir est une étape difficile
qui nécessite un homme que les libyens
doivent choisir correctement pour ne pas
le regretter
proche de khalifa haftar le président du
parlement aguila salaires s'était
également porté candidat ces derniers
jours en septembre l'homme de 77 ans a
ratifié unilatéralement une loi
électorale qui semble taillé sur mesure
pour le maréchal haftar désormais
candidat il assure vouloir oeuvrer pour
la réconciliation nationale
je cherche à établir un régime
démocratique qui assure la liberté la
justice et l'égalité à tous les
individus de la société sans distinction
et la participation des citoyens à la
vie politique et aux domaines économique
et social enfin dernier des candidats
les plus connus seïf al islam kadhafi
le fils de l'ancien dirigeant mouammar
kadhafi s'est lancé dans la course à la
présidence il est pourtant poursuivie
depuis 2011 pour crimes contre
l'humanité
l'annoncé de la candidature du
descendant de mouammar kadhafi qui a
gouverné la libye pendant 42 ans avant
de se faire tuer en 2011 laisse
dubitative une grande partie de la
population
je considère la nomination de seïf al
islam comme injuste car il est toujours
recherché par la cour pénale
internationale et à de nombreux
jugements contre lui en plus du fait que
c'est une figure controversée
vaty travailler à partir de la situation
actuelle du pays où va-t-il faire un pas
en arrière le scrutin du 24 décembre
s'annonce pour le moment serré et
indécis il s'agit de la première
élection d'un chef d'état au suffrage
universel en libye elle est considérée
comme déterminante pour le retour à la
stabilité d'un pays qu de sanglants
affrontements n'ont cessé de meurtrir
ces dix dernières années
autre pays dans une situation complexe
l'afghanistan où d'après l'onu 22
millions de personnes seraient menacées
par une grave pénurie alimentaire soit
plus de la moitié de la population
une situation qui inquiète les
commerçants de kaboul alors que les
clients se font plus rares reportage
dans la capitale afghane signet antoine
claireaux notre envoyé spécial
tous les indicateurs économiques sont au
rouge depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir des
talibans plus d'un afghan sur deux est
sans emploi est pour beaucoup la seule
perspective possible consiste à
s'expatrier pour trouver un travail un
avenir
c'est par exemple le cas de ce jeune
homme revenu au pays voir les siens il
est désormais coincé à kaboul dominé à 6
musd aille à la beauté au masculin
ma famille est là et moi je travaille à
moscou quand je suis arrivé tout allait
bien et puis la situation s'est dégradée
on a fermé l'aéroport je n'ai pas pu
partir d'ici la nuit nous avons mal au
coeur en pensant à notre vie qui est si
difficile
c'est comme ça
les autorités elles disent faire le
maximum pour assurer une continuité
économique en commençant par exemple par
verser les salaires des fonctionnaires
nous faisons de notre mieux avec ce que
nous avons nous avons payé un mois de
salaire à nos fonctionnaires qui
travaillent dans divers départements et
ministère
notre cabinet et le ministère des
finances ont annoncé qu'il verserait 3
mois de salaire que l'administration
précédente devait à ses fonctionnaires
nous allons donc leur payer cela
j'espère donc que tout ceci contribuera
à améliorer la situation économique
pourtant il faudra encore du temps pour
remettre l'économie en route avec une
banque centrale paralysé aux premières
loges les commerçants qui se plaignent
du manque de transactions de l'absence
d'activité
al batha
bien sûr nous espérons que la situation
économique s'améliore inchallah si dieu
le veut nous l'espérons ici tout est lié
à la sécurité si la sécurité est assurée
inchallah la situation économique
s'améliorera
maintenant ça va mieux qu'avant les gens
viennent et tout va bien quand le
business reviendra tout ira encore mieux
mais tout va bien pour l'instant ce look
est qu
un business man le pouvoir en place se
défend en déclarant avoir hérité d'un
pays à l'économie en lambeaux et subir
désormais le poids des sanctions
économiques internationales
d'où les difficultés actuelles
mais ces sanctions sont très
préjudiciables à notre peuple les gens
n'ont pas accès à de l'argent liquide
les banques ne peuvent pas fonctionner
même les organisations humanitaires qui
veulent aider les afghans ne peuvent pas
apporter d'argent ne peuvent pas retirer
de l'argent ne doivent pas rémunérer
leurs personnels techniques cela
exacerbe et aggrave la situation
humanitaire en afghanistan
l'afghanistan semble aujourd'hui frappée
d'une double peine entre une catastrophe
humanitaire et son isolement politique
sur la scène mondiale malgré les efforts
affichés la tâche paraît considérable et
il faudra encore du temps au nouveau
gouvernement pour affirmer sa légitimité
et c'est la fin de cette émission demain
vous avez rendez vous avec stéphanie de
murs yeux à 20h d'ici là n'oubliez pas
de réagir de commenter de poser vos
questions sur le conte télégramme
d'ayrté france prochain point sur l'actu
dans une trentaine de minutes avant 2
heures vous avez rendez vous avec car
pissavy yvernault très bonne soirée à
toutes et à tous
[Musique]
alors de la coop 26 et d'un g20
particulièrement tourné sur le climat
comment répondre à nos besoins
énergétiques tout en prenant en compte
les défis environnementaux comme
d'habitude